hi i'm jeremy renner and i play hawkeye
i'm sorry hi i'm jeremy
we're never going to make it justice no
i mean are you ready
oh i'm ready relax you're going to get
your head out of place hi
ready
did we really just stop dewey
no don't make it do it again
no i'm ready i'm so ready let's go
hi i'm jeremy renner and i play hawkeye
and i'm haley steinfeld and i play kate
bishop we are here today with buzzfeed
to take an mcu trivia quiz to find out
just how much we know about the marvel
cinematic universe now you can click the
link below and take a quiz along with us
ready
first in captain america the first
avenger we learned that captain
america's shield is made out of what
steel copper vibranium bronze vibrate
bingo correct the only one i think i'm
gonna get right okay in the avengers
what infinity stone does loki wield
using his scepter space stone soul stone
power stone mine stone mine stone i
would say mine stone mine stone is
correct yeah because that's the thing
that hypnotized me and made me a loki
there you go dude in the age of ultron
you're gonna get this okay at tony
stark's party who is the first avenger
to try and lift thor's hammer is it
clint barton
well that's just uh that's the only one
no i'm just asking if i'm asking
steve rogers we all need choices okay
bruce banner tony stark i think it's
tony stark
what is it am i right no no it's me yes
sorry you guys probably got it right of
course
i don't know wrong what are you telling
me barton clinton makes fun of thor's
hammer and then is the first person to
try and lift it push it i tried to set
you up there i don't know true or false
spider-man and sam wilson are both on
team cap and captain america civil war
who
sam wilson and spider-man
no false false correct yeah
okay which of these stan lee cameos
happens in thor ragnarok someone
attending a party i need my uh superhero
magnifiers
a fedex worker a barber someone reading
a script oh damn
do you know what it is or you don't know
no no anybody here
phone
do you guys i don't know it's not a
fedex worker i was between someone at a
party at a bar to the party someone at a
party yeah it was a farmer's shoot
oh okay i'm terrible this game i hope
you guys are doing better than us all
right in avengers end game what is
natasha's final line when she and clint
are on vermeer i was in that scene i
have no idea you don't i don't know i
didn't hear the i say it like i do i
don't i have to hear them
it's okay goodbye clint see you later no
no it's tell them yourself that's not an
option
you should be telling yourself oh i know
it's like when she says
okay you're right it's okay it's okay i
forgot she jumps it's okay yeah final
answer boom correct
all right that's that's that's a burrito
that's right she jumps off the cliff by
the way it's really affecting my
personal life it breaks my heart that
scene okay in one division what is the
name of billy and tommy's dog that
agatha kills sparky it can't be lucky
yeah i i say sparky sparky yeah
all right and finally in black widow
what does elena give to natasha when
they say goodbye after taking down the
red room a scrapbook filled with her
family memories elena's vest with a lot
of pockets a picture of elena and
natasha from when they were kids elena's
old my little pony stuffed animal it's
not the best she wouldn't give up the
best i don't think how about a picture
of them when they were kids what do you
guys think you have an idea no it's not
we're gonna squish through photo of them
all right all right all right
how did we do five out of eight it's an
okay day for us yeah yeah you know i
think if i retook the quiz again now i'd
still i might do worse be sure to stream
hawkeye on disney plus the next quiz we
take is gonna be a hawkeye quiz i'm
ready
are you